kevin what's going on man my wife and i
are having a communication issue
and uh we've been pretty good at hard
conversations in the past but uh
we're stuck on one and i think this will
turn into kind of a broader conversation
about
um you know having hard conversations
and stuff so but the example that we've
been
dealing with and struggling with lately
is kind of a night time routine
we're both really really busy through
the day i i have
i'm a supervisor at work and i got a lot
on my plate
and she's got three little kids um
to deal with our kids are amazing and
she's
you know a full-time mom with them and
uh our
our night time routine's a little wonky
like uh i'm an early bird i need to get
up early
and so i would like to get to bed early
but she is a night owl and she craves a
lot of
uh connection once you know all the kids
are in bed and i
crave that connection too like i need to
uh we need to connect with each other
and
um 2020 was um
it was a hard year for a lot of people
but for us we were
able to connect with each other more
yeah and it was what was one of the best
years of my life actually because we
finally got on the same page with a lot
of things very cool
and and so talking at night and
we have some great alone time together
we'll watch a tv show and then we'll
just
you know talk and have conversations put
down the distractions we have good
conversations but then
um the time creeps by and
it gets to be you know 11 11 30 midnight
and i'm looking at the clock and i'm
like i got to get up early
and i you know
have stepped on a lot of land lines in
the past couple weeks where i
will say all right well you know thanks
for talking i love you
and i you know i got to get to bed and
it just really hurts your feelings
because
she craves kind of that quantity of time
she wants a lot of time to talk so
anyway how how do you what do you
recommend how do you um
what advice you have for our couples who
just um i i crave that connection that
really really helps me it's helped a lot
over the last year but like
when when the physical meets you got to
go to bed right
exactly yeah so my my house is exactly
different my me and my wife's schedules
are exactly different and i'll tell you
how we worked through it first was
she my wife needs nine or ten hours of
sleep and i used to think
that was ridiculous and silly and that
she was being dramatic
dude i i have a different human living
in my house when she gets seven hours of
sleep versus nine
it's a different human right
and i would get home from work we had
the exact opposite when the kids
um were in bed she wanted to
crawl into bed and be in bed by 8 30.
there's no reason on earth to be awake
after 9 30.
what in the world is happening after 9
30. and i'm the opposite i was
working i work i have hard conversations
with people all day my head's spinning
all day
i get home and i just want to veg out i
want to kind of almost take a little
rest time between
six and eight six and nine and then we
can get up and like
then the rest of the evenings hours
right an evening being nine to about
midnight right
and um so ultimately
i had to realize two things number one
nobody in our house is help
healthy or whole if they're not getting
the sleep they need
so that became priority number one okay
so what that what did that mean that
mean i had to adjust me
she also had could adjust up another 30
minutes or another hour
okay so we've settled ish on 9 30 or 10
and what i learned with me is that what
i thought was i needed with
was craving with connection time and
just hangout time
i needed to be asleep man i was
exhausted i was
chronically exhausted all the time and
i moved from one thing to another thing
to another thing trying to just
prop myself up to stay awake stay awake
stay awake because then i was like i
finally get this time
man that ended up being a disaster so
i've learned over the last five to seven
years
um man if i'm up past 9 30 or 10 now
i am i hate everything i hate everything
right i love going to bed now and so
it took me changing my
thoughts it took me how about this
here's a way to practice it
when you get home and you help with
bedtime do you help with the bedtime
routine
yeah i do good deal a lot that's awesome
man so you help with the bedtime routine
structure that after bedtime
structure that time sometimes it feels
like this
this amorphous just quote unquote time
together
you sit down and structure hey what are
you looking for in this time
right what do you need from me and when
i finally got to where my wife
i just want to talk to another grown-up
adult human being that i can be
open with and vulnerable with i need
physical touch
i want to just watch a show and laugh
right and so
it kept this amorphous time my wife
would ask me what do you need man and
then finally i realized i need to go to
bed
i need to go to bed so structure that
time together
give each other 30 to 60 days
ask your wife hey can we go to bed at 10
30 right we're going to have the kids oh
by the way here's another quick question
when your kids go to bed
when they go to sleep so we've gotten
a lot better um before it was like just
whenever but now
we literally start bedtime at seven and
try and have them in bed by eight
and it's that's been so much better but
now we have
we literally we have so much time after
eight that we're just
continuously you know having
conversations and
and um one thing i will say it is
uh like i said it's been helpful because
like
i had a really bad habit and
talking to her and talking things
through with her really helped me kick
that habit and so like
talking with her really really has been
so helpful and so like
it's hard for me to imagine like not
having that conversation but then
it always hits that late hour and it's
like dang i i'm exhausted like i have a
an hour-long commute you know and i'm
like
worried i'm going to fall asleep on the
road and drink lots of soda i don't
really want to be drinking yeah i don't
do that
so do don't don't apologize for the
sleep you need okay
yeah and everyone does that differently
i have to have eight hours of sleep or
i'm useless my wife has to have ten
that means we're gonna have a gap there
okay it just does it just means we're
gonna have a gap or she's gotta have
nine
um and i've gotta be okay with that
she's gotta be okay that we both gotta
act like adults
and that also means that we've gotta
have the time that we do have has to be
focused i can't be
talking to her and just nodding while
i'm scrolling right and if we're gonna
watch a show we do
we have show night on wednesday that's
our that's i shoot
my shows on monday tuesday wednesday
generally and um
so i'm tired i'm super tired wednesday
nights that's when we all
we laugh and we put on a silly show and
watch some silly show right
um i would recommend putting in it's
gonna sound so ridiculous like you're
ten again
i would recommend putting in a bedtime
at ten o'clock the lights go out
and i'm gonna ask you wife that we turn
the lights off and that you will
stay in bed that you will turn the
lights off too at 10 or if you need to
read you know for another 15-20 minutes
let's do that for 30 days can we just
commit to that together
and then you those two hours that are
just y'alls are just
lasered in on each other whatever that
means whatever that looks like for y'all
if that's intimate time if that's just
chit chatting time
if that is doing budget time together
checking on calendar stuff
those two hours are just rich gold
between the two of you
but then at 10 the lights are gonna go
out and letting her know hey
i not in this uncertain like i've got a
lot of things on my plate when you
approach it that way
her immediate response is well i got a
lot of crap on my plate too dude
so don't approach it with here's how
hard this burden is
approach it the other way which is i
need this much sleep
and i need this much connection time
with you so here's how we can do both of
them
kids are in bed by eight o'clock then we
got two solid hours of just one another
and then at 10 o'clock i gotta turn the
lights out
and just try it my guess is you will
modulate up half an hour or down half an
hour
but if she's anything like me i just
wanted the knight to keep going and keep
going and keep going
and dude now i am 9 30 nerd
deluxe i had just never done it before
right
so practice that time it with
intentionality
let her know not how busy you are let
her know i've got to have this much
sleep
i've just got to and i want to be fully
present when i'm here i want to do my
best job at work but i really want to
help with the kids i really want to love
these children well and i really want to
love you well as you said
as we've done this year that's so
awesome that 2020 has been a good
connection year for you
i'm hearing that all over the country
couples who just decided to
reimagine what their world was going to
be like but hey
for 30 days this this idiot on the radio
said let's try 30.
let's try turn the lights off at 10
o'clock let's just try it and don't get
out of bed because i used to just jump
up she turned the lights off at 9 30 to
10 then i'd go hang out and watch tv
till midnight
and then i just turned into this drippy
exhausted sloppy just mess
just and then i'd get up and be late to
work but just don't do that
say for 30 days to stay in bed until 10.
let's try it
let's just try it you can even hold
hands as you all go to sleep look how
romantic that was
friday morning romance here on the john
delaney show
um let me know how that goes call me
back in 30 days or have her call me
y'all both call me back and i want to
see
how the romance is deepening in kevin's
house
because we're all going to bed at the
same time